Marcus how does a kid who grew up in
Ventura end up acting in LA you have a
really supportive high school drama
teacher who takes you to a acting class
in Los Angeles and you have to deal with
the fact that you really suck and you
have to unlearn everything you thought
you know and you stick to it and you
take the criticism and you grow from it
and you hone your craft and eventually
your acting coach in LA introduces you
to an agent who happens to be his wife
and you audition for them and they take
you on and then you start auditioning
for things and if you're lucky you get
to read for a show created by Steven
Bochco and they hire you and it does
well and you impress a guy like Steven
Bochco and he invites you to join a
television series that's how it happened
for me you know back in the 1600s I
don't know how it works now but right I
mean that's so so just rewinding a
little bit I mean Ventura is a beautiful
town yes it's more of like sort of a
family environment
yes very much and you're it's what two
hours away from LA just probably by now
the traffic wise I mean it's normally
should be an hour but there's a lot of
there's a lot of traffic here that it
used to not be here so it's it's wow
it's probably say about an hour and a
half okay so you you were taking drama
classes and was that your plan all along
today no I thought I wanted to be an
architect I was horrible at math Wow and
I couldn't draw but I was gonna be an
architect I saw but I had a teacher and
her husband was an architect and they
look very fancy to me so I was like okay
well to be fancy go be an architect and
I was terrible at math I didn't know you
needed that I didn't know what she
needed to be an architect I just wanted
to fancy
but my drama teacher was smart enough to
say maybe try this instead I don't know
if that architect's stuff's gonna work
out so well with your math grades so
that's kind of how that happened I like
I'm sorry in Rupp I'm like how you said
that you didn't know what you needed to
be an architect what do you think people
need to be an actor that's coming you
drove two hours I think you need and
this probably is a little bit unpopular
nowadays I think you need talent mm-hmm
I think you need more of them talent I
think you need drive and ambition and
especially in today's landscape you need
to have at least a base understanding of
the way the business works and you have
to understand where you fit in you know
people look at you casting directors and
such they're looking at your picture to
set a role and if you look like me
you're not going to look like the guy
that Chris Pine is gonna play you know
what I mean so you have to understand
that you have to know where you fit you
have to be able to navigate that in a
realistic way it doesn't mean that you
can't get to where you want to go but
you do have to be able to operate within
the industry as it is right now and how
you fit into it right now and I think
that sort of realism mixed with talent
hard work drive and ambition is what
brings us these people that kind of come
up out of nowhere and break the molds
you know I mean
you